[Music]
all right well thank you everybody for
coming out tonight we are here we have
arrived at the end of a very long
journey this is the semi-soft part 10 of
10 and tonight we'll be checking out the
anti Moscow save the best for last
and I recommend highly when you play
these lines so you're going to see
tonight that you're a computer and not a
human they're not very human friendly
these lines are crazy they get
ridiculous and it's very hard to be a
human and play these lines and for some
reason tonight we're going to show it
from whites point of view to highlight
you know my personal bias towards this
line and we'll get right to it let's
just really quick get back to the semi
slob we're looking still at the Bishop
g5 lines we had a look at the bottleneck
taking on c4 tonight we're again going
to look at h6 we looked at the
positional lines that can occur when
they take on f6 in our last video but
tonight we're going to look at perhaps
one of the most normal moves you could
play in this position right I don't want
to give up the bishop pair so I just
maintain the pin if you do nothing you
develop and I'll just play III and life
is great
well black here is going to do something
kind of risky he's going to do a
combination of taking and holding on to
this pond mixed in with g5 to make sure
that he can win upon for example after
they take efore getting ready to go e5
so g5 so they don't get this as a pin
and black holds on to the pond so it's
very risky to play this way as black it
is true that you're up a pawn but you've
pushed pawns on all sides of the board
you only have one pawn left to push I
guess you got to but this is not all
you've done like a whole lot of damage
white is way ahead in development and
it's their turn so we're going to see
what we can do can like get an
initiative
how can you prove that you have
something worth upon here
and we really going to be looking at the
main line today which is Bishop to e2
because Bensimon for some reason doesn't
want a ten-part series on the anti
mosque al I don't know why but you know
that's whose call executive producer
that he is who's getting ready for it
this is actually a highly theoretical
line so we really could do a whole bunch
of parts on this but we're going to
limit it to just one today so we look at
the main mind develop your stuff
there should be two you're going to
Castle and White has a whole lot of
plants that might come up in all of
these positions if Y can ever
successfully play them of d5 like yeah
usually is crushing the opening up the
center because White's way ahead and
development so a lot of these lines why
just looking to play d5 he also has the
other breaks available a for b3 a lot of
the times he can play h4 he has a whole
lot of ways that he can change the pawn
structure and try to open up the
position pretty early on also e5 will be
played a lot of the times followed by
another Knights coming in and looking at
some of these squares so White has a
whole bunch of plans and it's blacks job
to kind of hold on here
now you have to already be really
careful here with black you can already
go really wrong and basically there's
only one move here basically you can
play the other stuff but it's not so
obvious to see the main move in this
position is Bishop to b7 a prophylactic
move you're trying to prevent the d5
idea from white White's going to push d5
and open it all up
if for example you play the most natural
moves with just develop your knight
Knight B to d7 now d5 comes and this is
supposed to just be really good for
white for example in the highest-rated
black game in which this was played Zhu
Chen versa Lexie drea from 1999
there's a whole bunch of moves I mean
you can you can take either way or you
can play Bishop to b7 this is the main
move and that was drea move so let's
take a quick look at how fast things can
actually start to go wrong for black
okay so we get to take and in a lot of
these lines we're hoping at some point
to push here get this Knight out of the
way and this check can be really
disruptive so here we see we go after
this pawn fill and black defends that we
push our EEP on to one the knight moves
we can at some moment we don't have to
do it immediately pops let's check in
and kind of disrupt the black king in
this game white just castles which is
fine black doesn't have a good way of
really preventing Bishop to h5 so after
here
Bishop age five and you get a position
like this and black still has this pawn
but it's going to get kind of dangerous
for his King for example we have some
targets we'll just show a couple more
moves here and in this position if you
put this on your engine then they'll be
like White's just totally crushing Black
has no chance and that being said black
went on to win so well yeah this is
supposed to just be really good for why
you're all of your pieces are so active
and black like have some issues but in
the game there was lots of swindling and
white made a lot of mistakes so the
black was able to win this game but we
will talk about it so going back so this
would be to line the knight B to d7 I'm
a fake
also an interesting mistake is b4 with
the idea of removing the defender of
efore and I do want to show this game
only because there's one move I want to
show you so let's just look at the idea
so we move our Knight and they take our
econ what's so bad about this unit looks
great I'm about to take your Bishop
that's going to be great well we're
going to move our Bishop this is the e5
attacks the rook
so after your knife drops back we can
bring our pieces in and it's again like
most of these lines it's all about
having the more active pieces that's
going to matter a lot more than the
material and we're going to sort of see
some dramatic examples of that tonight
all right I'm on your seat pawn so try
to get rid of it just castle g4 and now
the only reason to show you this game is
this next move I'll give you guys a
chance i tacked your knife let's see
let's just it's also interesting these
positions to try to put you into these
positions and get the audience involved
what would you guys do here with white
deck tonight okay you want to play rough
b1 okay this is a very interesting move
so I will I will take it and I'll just
see what you had in mind which waited
with the bishop okay even though your
bishops hanging oh you're taking this
way first okay so a very interesting
idea so so far you have sacrificed a
piece and I guess I should be careful
here now am I going to defend all my
stuff okay I'm going to I don't really
can't really move my knight - then
you're taking my C pawn so I guess I'll
have to block and you'll get all these
crazy stuff where even though you're
down a piece like who knows you might
have compensation here and that's how
like all these lines work but uh perhaps
I'd defend it a little bit I don't know
if this was the most accurate way but
thinking of sacrificing the knight is
correct in a lot of these positions
that's not okay and one of the moves you
can play here is Nike one that's too
obvious I attacked your night enables
away that's way too obvious in here I
can take care and trade lots of stuff so
let's just keep trading in this guy's
attack we can defend it and something
like this is about equal you could do
that or you could play a super awesome
fantastic amazing move and this is why I
say it's better to be a computer so
tonight we're going to kind of pander to
our computer audience the uprising is
coming so as soon as the computers take
over you know you know try to get all
their viewership and to the chest
buildings explained because there's so
many moves that like don't make any
sense and what often happens I mean
especially it's a high level but even
amateur level when people are preparing
against somebody that might play this
way is either color as soon as somebody
has some new idea or move that you don't
know and they've looked at it with their
computer you might be in a lot of
trouble because you can lose like on the
spot at any single point so things get
very dangerous very quickly and like
computer only moves need to be found in
every position and one of those moves
that might not jump out at you is just
the move Queen to b3 so the same sort of
idea but now if you take here and I take
back and you play the same way I have 97
I think unless anyone's cheating with
the computers and they could tell me I'm
wrong that looks pretty good for me so
it is a little bit different with the
Queen there and so what should happen is
they shouldn't take your night they
should like just take the other night
and then you can take those a game or
like yeah just don't take all so good
pin stuff and finally this position
occurred and none of these moves need to
make any sense
but uh position is about equal somehow
so there's gonna be all sorts of moves
like this in every position that that's
why it would take us 10 part series to
actually go over every possible
continuation a lot of these lines but
just to give you some idea in this
position the main move not nice B to d7
not be 4 but Bishop to b7 ok and we're
getting closer to the main line castles
Knight B to d7 and okay black is going
to probably play Bishop g7 and Castle if
you do nothing we do have to take some
action now pretty soon here is white
wiggler stuff out and we castled black
still has a couple turns away from
castling and i can consider maybe going
to either side but uh now white brings
the action to black and we're just going
to look at that main move which develop
your stuff and I'm ready to castle
everything's great and we're actually
going to look at two moves in this
position the main move is to take on d7
and we're going to come back and look at
a kapal off game where he came up with
the novelty Knight takes f7 particularly
good in bug house then blacks in a lot
of trouble but let's just first have a
look at the main line so here we go cake
and also this one is going to be crazy
and what's funny is you know it's only a
couple hundred times in the database but
like every move here is forced because
you only got here if you use two
pewter and you play a bunch of computer
moves and then eventually somebody
doesn't know what's going on and then
you know everybody blunders and a lot of
these games you know like the top level
it's just everybody blunders every
single move because it's impossible it
doesn't matter how good you are
world champion doesn't matter everybody
blunders every move because you know at
some point these positions break down
and stop making any sense
but only move here Bishop to d6
preventing you from castling all right a
six a four e five you get the e five
break in okay and this Bishop it's
actually really common this Bishop will
go to one of these two squares you need
to do something active he's not the best
here he's just looking at a wall so
Bishop to g4 it's a common idea okay and
now the move there's only one move here
so again I'll test the class and we'll
see you know if there's any computers in
the audience because no human could ever
play this if they've never seen it
except for Danny which you complete it
but we'll talk about that so one reason
you'd want to play this is as black is
you know the dispositions main line and
then your phone that doesn't know stuff
they just lose right away so both sides
have chances to lose right away and
that's kind of why you play the semi
Slav in general it's you know it's
really confusing it's a great way to try
to win because it gets so complicated
it's the most complicated opening and
all of chess which I took a ten part but
yeah you have to you know nerves of
steel here does anyone have any ideas
b5 okay the master in the audience was
able to get it right
yeah b5 then if you take look all right
I got the e5 break and the c5 break-in
if you take what actually has a winning
move so if you play d5 you probably sell
this move
maybe blunder your knight give me your
knight
right so it's tough it's it's obviously
easy to give all your pieces away in
this kind of position
what about e6 all right very good
this is actually the winning move for
white and then some computer defense to
only be kind of a little bit worse who
knows what is funny is it have to be
losing I'm up at night I got that going
for me but you're checkmating me all
right I'll play some random move 95
you're checkmating me why not bring it
on and then you know pawn takes pawn
check okay brilliant stuff they might
solve some of my issues yeah and that's
the thing even though you're probably
winning who knows what the computer said
but rook e1 first don't attack my thing
and puts pressure on the e-file I don't
want you to do that why'd you have to go
go do that okay No
you don't care ok you don't care I don't
care with confusion that's how you play
this maximal confusion and then the
better calculator will so it's also good
if you're a lower rated opponent tune
you're trying to be the higher rated
opponent because it's know nobody knows
what's going on ever impossible Queen d4
what a move yeah Knight f3 27 looks like
a defense move alright so with my queen
yeah well you can think I'm faking
obviously but I'm taking on g4 with
confusion
alright we're still playing on here
no I'm will come off on but that's
that's the point even if and that
happens to like you'll even realize okay
I'm losing or something there's always
time to come back because there's
massive calendar play all the time and
every piece could sacrifice them so you
know that's also cool if you're you know
you're losing you always have chances to
come back some openings you're just
you're down a piece like you're just
down a piece there's no counter play
there's nothing here anything can always
happen especially you know lower rated
opponents lots of mistakes can be made
because it's too hard and too confusing
and you have to find computer only moves
but instead in this position you can
play them with c5 get to c5 in there
rook e1 Knight takes so black
now sax the piece just so you can castle
but your night is still attacked all
right very confusing 92 yeah here I go
just push push my pod and then most
humans that give the knight right back
if you're the computer yeah you play
like b3 but no human has ever done that
ever and then why is because of the
great black response King h8 notice I'm
I'm starting to take here and then put
my Queen here to go here and win that
Fonda
so yeah King h8 that's why they don't do
it the most normal position you could
ever have this is the main line it is
this is the main main line so very
standard you know and then 0 0 0 this
looks like hundreds of games from this
position yeah this is the main main line
big draw but you know good luck actually
drawing this against anybody decent
because still too confusing but that is
the main line so we return
to this position after Bishop to g7 and
we're going to look now at the game to
pull off kramnik from I think it says
2008 that sounds right it was played in
a vikon's a and okay this move just got
unleashed first time ever just take on a
seven nights of meaningless piece just
get that King out there and attack so
very very aggressive stuff all right so
it was taken and as we sort of saw
before one of the ideas of kicked this
guy away so we can disrupt the King d5
fish of h5 probably an okay move instead
he went here first with a threat King
just moved over
in the night they'll jump in I'm on your
Bishop let the normal move you like
shocked at that move
you don't care okay he protected it so
far so far so good
H score is audience suggested but now
I'll do whatever move is good for me if
you did nothing just see five typical
break and make sure when you're playing
this you go like this a lot
that's like essential right slam pieces
especially I feel like you know it's a
dubious just slam it and look it scared
also important an h4 isn't really to the
point I don't know if that actually did
for you
to give some big point you're going to
open wise you wanted to open the H file
you're hoping I'd take it
what are they when you were about to
like open the H file for me yeah no not
not really to the point so after Queen
to b6
so if Bishop stage 5 isn't really check
we'll go to G for another active square
now the King is kind of tied down to
this pond maybe when you're not
expecting I'll sack on e6 drag your king
out especially in bug house this is very
friendly to white in bug house so so
take note of that don't don't play this
way in book oh you should if you're
white yeah yeah let your opponents play
this way so far I assume white was still
in this prep here he came up with the
move Queen to c2 and now it's
kramnik to move and blunder but what's
funny is this has been played I'm gonna
show I'll show you briefly another game
the next day after this in the other
section of Vikon say in the lower
section those two 2500 and we'll take a
look at that it was Tim on in Liguria
vich and so blacks they both seemed this
game I guess black played the best move
here he went home and studied it and
then they played it the next day so
that's how fast theory can change in
these lines and also I when I was
considering like I'm going to show them
a most highly theoretical the most
modern stuff from this open angle it's
like it changes all the time any time
any top-level player plays lifts there's
some new idea so there's still so much
to like learn about this kind of
position so I'll get to see if you guys
can play the right move here so
obviously kramnik head you'll never seen
this so it's impossible but uh I guess
what would you guys guys play here
you'll notice that D pawn hanging do
notice it you want to take it okay good
don't take it because the kramnik took
it don't take it
and yeah that's that's when things start
to go wrong in general white wants to
open everything up because you're Kings
on e7 and I got all these open bishops
and all these pieces attacking you so
it's always going to be in wife's
interest to open things up so in the
other game that was played the very next
day we'll come back and look at Queen
takes d4 okay rook H to g8 was played
understanding you know that white is
coming in and now almost every single
move in this game we won't talk about
too much is a blunder like every move is
a blunder from here on out to tough this
is Kim and Lavoie ovitch from like on
say 2008 the next day
a4 and now black should take on d4 the
pawns hanging what he saw the other game
where I was like never right to open the
position so steady one here and then
like I think the computer was like you
need bonds hanging defend your pawn but
he didn't he's not afraid to open it up
but black never does that
and then black goes on to win and then
somewhere and then this move was like
horrible you blundered upon like
horrible just take it and now blacks
winning
how could you blend your upon and he's
trying to open the position which is you
know what you want to do here is white
but uh you know I'm just gonna try to
keep it as close as possible white wants
to open it up okay you get your queen in
there and then like ever every move here
was wrong so we're not gonna talk about
any of it but because it's impossible to
play this position so alright so now
look at the bloopers loop yeah all right
we want to talk about it because it is
it's too hard and everything was a
mistake no one can play these positions
okay so going back though to our main
game okay so he took there
and now I'll put you guys into white
shoes here you guys get to play for the
winning side okay good so they kind of
opened up position a little bit but what
moves you like have in mind here yeah
queen g6 yeah just come right on in okay
you're on the bishop and I'll somehow he
didn't find the supercomputer move the
easiest move anybody's ever played
Bishop to f6
was not played the easiest move to ever
play no and then the computer like takes
this and then you take here followed by
like complicated crazy nonsense and then
too complicated I think I was here yeah
like so it's yeah the easiest thing to
ever play in your life and black you
know probably and I think I've finished
here all right bad for black but
practical chances to survive alright but
okay you didn't find Bishop f6 because
it's hard to calculate or consider I
know you would have but you know you're
The Fresh Prince
okay so stead blacks up here so trading
Bishop one problem is the night banging
and then open it up and what's funny to
is that after this unlike the other game
that was played in the other section of
the tournament like from this point on
they play great like so now they you
know so it was really just one
miscalculation and then that just lost
the game so now only both play great
like a fans well and white play well and
so white wins
cuz it's alright just let's open it up
let's attack it so black does is best to
keep it closed push to keep it closed do
not attack me c4
take the clean check
my clean and white here you know looks
like maybe oh we're just going to repeat
or whatever what sex the Queen you know
perfectly natural and a crazy line like
this but I want an entirely necessary I
mean you can consider playing h3 to
drive that queen away or just a trade
queen but okay interesting opening it
wide up yes you get him
then I take check and okay things are
looking pretty bleak now it's starting
to become more obvious as the position
simplifies that black I sort of in
control here alright a little back and
forth and from here for you know these
guys it's just a simple technical task
but you know still very complicated to
class players are playing in this then
you know any result is possible but okay
wait displayed well from here them out
very scary
finally this guy gets role in all these
those are like great and here resigns
instead of the best mover picks G - yeah
that's a bad bad just that your best
move
okay so really this is a fantastic prep
flight appalled off and that will
conclude it for us that was the anti
Moscow hopefully you guys enjoyed it
we're going to go play the tournament
now so we're going to see how well you
guys can play out these positions that's
going to be the most fun and okay we're
going to I think a lot of people have
had some good suggestions for what they
want to see next so may be able to get
some of your comments down below
whatever you guys want to see I'll take
one of your guys's openings you want to
be explained here coming up for the next
episode and thank you everybody for
joining us on this very long journey
thanks for your patience staying with it
thanks for all the positive feedback hit
like share subscribe and we'll see you
guys next week
[Music]